and this you've just seen two properties
today this one is in really good
condition it's how many bedrooms six six
five and this which is just big enough
respect and you bought this for how much
one two seven nine Clues final smoke all
the furniture TLC doing and we're going
to ship because the village is a bit
rubbish 107 four five bedrooms really
six to five boxes five boxes of old one
good condition yes so near the center
Rory could walk to the center
how many Mia seven minutes from this
point four miles which is great
next is minimum of four
to the ropes which you've smashed next
is left engaging in the area James is
going to be managing these problems for
you and then lastly is 25 grand per room
which we've beat yeah so that's
fantastic so right let's keep up in our
book congratulations good to meet you
Carlo seems pretty nice
[Music]
so now they're already furnished and
doesn't we need anything into the talk
and think there
completely ready together do you know
why I think it is due to time and he's
got this one he's got another two bucks
you sell it to the interested radio so
we look around the house it turns out
that the landlord is from London and
he's getting a high street manager to
manager HMO rule number one never do
that why because unless they specialize
in HMOs Norlin agents will not be doing
a good job of money coach Mercer do you
guys agree with that so so you're going
to end up managing the property manager
and managing a property manager can be
just as difficult as managing tenants
which is why you need a special estate
to my manager which luckily we have in
Stoke so that's great next lesson from
this is where did we find these cue
houses from I mean buying a property for
a hundred and twenty seven and a half
thousand pounds which is six bedroom HMO
already up and running I mean geez where
do you find those kinds of deals the
last property that we just looked at
five bed heights mo good condition fire
doors and smoke alarms buying it for one
hundred and seven thousand pounds we're
an earthed you follow this deal from so
I think I'm gonna let rich Anne Elliot
answer those questions because they
found them so Richard where did you find
your deal from but I great come true
excellent
so go so is do you find a lot of
properties on gumtree yeah
excellent country where did you find
your failure right move right move you
know what right move sometimes people
say you can't find a good investment
property from right move I think that's
ridiculous because if you're a motivated
seller and you're wanting to sell your
house who's the first person you're
going to probably go to probably an
estate agent so presumably you've got a
good relationship with the estate agent
I imagine trains you how many be bought
from retrains we've probably bought
dozens dozens of yeah so what what you
need to do is the best way to build
relationship with estate agents the best
way to make friends with them is to just
buy from them once you've bought one or
two houses from an estate agent they'll
be bringing you the best stock before it
even hits might move so you know get
yourself friendly with estate agents
start buying never slip you know that's
their agent don't forget to be going on
gumtree search not online sending out
your letters if you want to be a deal
sourcing machine and can't just rely on
one strategy you need to do what
everything everything so I hope that's
helpful my stuff how you feel about the
two houses I'm over the moon
great good properties how has the
service been a by low-rent ha I haven't
you've been very good up in I feel like
I've been looked after by the by the
sources and yeah I mean and be
questioned about I've needed to uh
they've answered it and so yeah I'm and
where do you live in Manchester
Manchester and why do you use a sourcing
company rather than phone in your own
dales just because I haven't got the
time to go looking for myself and plus I
trust people that have been doing it
longer than me to get me bad deals yeah
eventually I might do it myself what for
now I guess painsaw what to 9,000 pounds
I mean it's not a lot in the big scheme
of things no you know and you know I did
a little bit myself and it does take a
bit of time you have to go searching
online right
yeah so yeah just let other people do it
Plouffe they know the area they've been
doing it for longer and you know they
know the location in the street well
we're not fun to seen you get tenants
for these houses absolutely good job
good job I've broke boobs right let's go
get some Nando's although you're not
eating are you mr. organic
[Music]
you